I don't think there was any way for Andy
and I to predict where we were going
when we were young
it was something we did because we loved
it truly making games I had always
thought that Andy and I as a team were
going to be successful but you know
Naughty Dog who would have thought he
would create knotted up
it wasn't like oh let's found a video
games do now we're 15 beats mowing lawns
his father said that's the dumbest thing
you're ever gonna do I mean you were on
computers what were you doing we thought
crash would do pretty well we didn't
anticipate it being the number one brand
foreplay stage at that point we still
weren't quite sure what we had we were
just blown away were like how are they
doing that it just kept on selling and
kept on selling it didn't slow in fact a
game and so naughty dog went through
explosive growth hire big think big
let's put everything we have into making
these games we wanted to stop building
levels and build worlds we were making
the games that the Moodle integrate
takes a lot of sweat sometimes tears
where was hard about making it hard like
everything the last of us was the
hardest game that I've ever made the
team that we built was a crash team and
then suddenly we have to design this
grounded game last post was even harder
because they got even more grounded and
our eyes were too big for our songs we
didn't really know what we were doing as
far as the tech I had somebody come in
my office quitting like every single
week we were losing more people than we
were hired and there was a sense that
Naughty Dog was a sinking ship
Naughty Dog's secret has always been to
hire the best people possible and now
people do say that's naughty dog game I
know it's going to be quality because I
know that team
basil